We've seen that we can apply area
roles and properties to an element
to modify the way it is exposed
in the accessibility tree.
The area practices doc helps us decide
what area roles and properties to use.
We're going to start with the radio
group example from lesson two.
You might remember we use the area
design patterns doc to get some guidance
as to what keyboard
handling we needed to add.
In this exercise we're going to
revisit the same example.
But we're going to follow the design
pattern guidance for the area role and
state on each radio button in the group.
Remember to make sure
the state is kept in sync
with the visual state of the button.
One quick note, the area design
pattern mentions area-labeled by and
area-described by, we're going to
skip those for this exercise.
But you'll be learning
more about them shortly.